bonjour factor bonjour françois bonjour
factor fait chaud pas vrai vous voulez
boire quelque chose je vous l'offre
c'est pas drôle on voit bien une
limonade et moi aussi julie ça va me
remonter le moral
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est pas la
monnaie je me suis trompé de bouteille
c'est la lessive pour nettoyer le coeur
vous voulez quelque chose dans non merci
ça suffit comme ça on va dit donc
broking aviez déjà pas le moral 1 et oui
facteur depuis que casimir est parti en
voyage
l'île aux enfants n'est plus tout à fait
la même on a l'impression que le jardin
est vide c'est pas pour moi que vous
dites sont bien sûr que non pas car au
contraire c'est très agréable de vous
voir et vous vous êtes toujours de bonne
humeur
même quand je vous fait voir de la
lessive à je dis toujours il vaut mieux
être gros et de bonne humeur que malgré
triste
là vous avez bien raison facteurs baroin
a dit porsche ag de lettres port aux
romains oui françois et j'ai reconnu
l'écriture de kazim et moi que si
l'afrique il a tué ses chers françois
recherche juhlin
je fais un voyage merveilleux moi j'ai
toujours eu envie de partir comme ça sur
un bateau tout seul à la découverte des
terres nouvelles ou jamais un homme
c'est vrai tant vous laisser terminer
l'année pardonnez moi je rêvais un petit
peu je vous en prie bon je continue
j'arrive par le prochain bateau signé
kazim est le prochain bateau c'est dans
deux jours c'est formidable
casimir où les gens moi ça tombait dans
ta lettre tu parlais du prochain bateau
wyatt pour sûr que la neige gelée un peu
oublié dans mon sac avatar mieux comme
ça on aura il a su retenir casimir pour
de toi quand tu vois c'est super mais on
vous dit que c'étaient les salles
d'armes et vous lui laissez pas placer
un mot et je crois que le facteur a
raison il faut lui laisser raconter tout
ce voyage j'ai plein de souvenirs de
beaucoup de vrai les enfants vous venez
et vous savez rien à risque par terre la
parfaire son art voilà voilà assis dans
l'herbe
voilà tout le monde est installé
tu viens ce pays tout le monde a une
place
la gale et aironi que des valets casimir
à nous raconter tout son voyage
vas-y casimir intégrité donc voilà
d'abord je suis parti dans une belle
montagne beaucoup il y avait les
attendait g j'ai oublié le nom mais j'ai
rapporté plaint d'un plein de bruits de
souvenirs de vacances dans ma malle
magique fait lui même ou des sacs
écouter à nos côtés ça écoutez bien les
enfants il était rien écoutez voilà vous
reconnaissez qu'est ce qu'il entend la
dissidente
le vol doit comme ça on n'est pas
l'école qu'est-ce que c'était des
cigales c'est les ségalis il ya ce que
c'est ça et ça c'est dans quel pays les
cigarettes dites moi en france mais dans
quelle partie de la france en province
j'ai comme militant c'est ça qui est mis
en avant et après vous attendez je suis
parti dans une autre région
oui on j'ai entendu des décors des
oreilles ou à écouter la magic la malle
magique on est
on attendait aussi écouter un petit peu
c'est tellement beau c'est tellement bon
qu'on s'y croirait à chaque fois on
écoute et un petit moment déjà dit toi
jean-françois démo est donc les moitiés
c'est la mienne c'est au bord de la mer
et c'était intense moment de la mort de
la mère ouais alors c'est entendu les
enfants on écoutait un petit peu c'est
tellement beau on se croirait il était
signé après que la grèce je suis allé
dans une une grande grande quoi par
écouter
[Musique]
casini une voiture c'est pas tout à fait
ça on entend des bruits de voitures nous
y at il des brides voiture sur
l'autoroute il y en a partout mais
particulièrement soto cano dans une
niche a émis cet élan dans un langage
non mais il y en a énormément dans une
villa dans une rapide dans la cause dans
une grande ville mais c'est ça après la
grande biya je suis parti quelques jours
dans une étude utilisés ou à écouter
écouter on écoute
voilà c'est ça mais on écoute à tous les
coups c'est une basse cour mais une
poule viala beaucoup même des poules je
crois qu'en général je m'interdis de
ferme c'est ça ouais tu l'étais casimir
ensuite un jour j'ai vu une 1h ils
avaient tous écouté gelé la wii a
beaucoup de mémoire mais l'on écoute
qu'on écoute à petit c'était dans une
course automobile et une grande course
automobile
voilà vous aimez le pinceau de mobiles
vous aimez ça les gars sont allés après
suite j'ai pu j'ai été dans un pays où
il y avait et mais dans le même temps
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est ce
qu'il a entendu
pas tout à fait identique sera entendue
c'est presque détendu
non c'est pas dans l'un des ses ça c'est
exactement ça christine des tam-tams des
tables et quelques amis ou c'était tout
à l'heure les frais
ouais avais tu as raison effectivement
il y en a aussi à tahiti ouais et alors
le derghal geo
il y a eu quelque chose de deux ans et
coûté ce qui est bienvenu à ce jour de
tes vacances voilà ouais on écoute des
sarthois la capap il ya eu un orage un
livre les derniers moteurs
qu'est-ce que c'était un orage et
qu'est-ce qu'il ya pendant leur âge il
pleut non mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya aussi
ce bruit vous avez très bien répondu
c'était du tonnerre
casimir il le fait un très beau voyage
en mai payer le design n'a pas eu de
chance ni raison mais les autres choses
tranquille j'ai voyagé avec des chants
vraiment très désagréable au bout des
gens désagréables mais qu'est ce qu'il
te disait parce qu'ils étaient très mal
poli très impoli du mot d'excusé écoute
ce qu'ils disent est en écoute en écoute
longtemps et casimir c'est ça quitte à
choquer ben ouais et alors